I've been asked by the FBI I've been
asked by the police to help with the FBI
or the police went out with
[Music]
[Applause]
psychological illusion doing
extraordinary television and even better
live shows Darren is a National Treasure
welcome to the show the story We Tell
ourselves is not what's real like for
example I did a show called Miracle the
Lord has his work cut out tonight and
the second half was healing the woman
came up and she'd been paralyzed on one
side of her body since she was four in
floods of Tears because she could move
her left arm for the first time what
you're seeing is that it's the
psychological component of suffering
right like nothing's happened nothing's
changed but their relationship to their
suffering that's been made to change
it's not the things in life that cause
your problems it's the story that you
tell yourself about them it's the
judgments that you make about them
there's a lot of people that are trying
to sell you on this [ __ ] that they
can take your traumas or your your
insecurities to zero I've never seen it
happen we've completely obliterated the
idea of just fortune and life sometimes
life's throwing stuff back at us if we
have no control over anxiety is still
somehow the demon but you know without
anxiety how do you know to change
anything you know you can't do that
without embracing anxiety to an extent
you were is predominantly based in
Psychology right so have you ever done
anything and thought how the [ __ ] did
that happen don't go home and start
doing that
two things come to mind
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
foreign
[Music]
the last few days reading all about your
childhood oh truly fascinating thank you
actually I've actually got a picture
here have you um
how strange that you have that picture
yes that's me with a um a parrot on my
shoulder after you have this little boy
yes
what do I need to understand about about
him
and the world he lived in and the way he
saw the world to understand you
what do you need to understand well I
was an only child till I was nine uh
so I guess that's kind of that's a
pretty formative thing isn't it
um
quite creative like always always
drawing and Building Things Lego
um
always been a bit of a people pleaser
and maybe that at that age
a kind of yeah sort of happy didn't have
a lot of friends there wasn't like a
didn't have a big gang I never really
did I've always gone through life just
with sort of a small number of of good
friends uh
but I think there's one that feels like
a happy a happy time to think back on I
remember sitting with Jimmy Carr and him
telling me that um people often think of
comedians as being like they're
depressed so they're trying to impress
other people to get some kind of thrill
for their own sort of self-gratification
but Jimmy said to me he said you should
actually ask which one of my parents
was depressed that I was trying to
impress to understand how I became a
comedian and I wonder you said that
you're a bit of a people pleaser
you clearly have this huge Affinity
towards entertaining and getting the
reaction back from people the amazement
where where did that start can you have
you pinpointed where that started in
your childhood
yes I think I could so when I was at
school so my dad was a swimming teacher
at school
and uh
he and I wasn't very sporty so I kind of
um it shielded me from being like
uh bullied as an as a non-sporty kid but
I didn't love school
mainly because I said I found a lot of
the kids
the sporty gets quite intimidating and
so on so I kind of like but Dad teaching
that helped and then when I got to and I
was I was in with the wrong group the um
the sort of classical music loving
group or the puff gang as we were less
charitably known
um didn't even like classical music so
it was a pretty miserable group to be
stuck with
um in sixth form I remember everybody
sort of seemed to grow up
suddenly become a lot more uh
friendly and so I kind of
uh
I sort of exploded in a way into sort of
like a attention seeking and I went from
being very sort of quiet and a bit a bit
intimidated by these sort of uh
kids to sort of um suddenly they seem to
sort of you know like me or at least you
know they were
fine so I I started doing impressions of
teachers and I would draw caricatures
with them and I was def I became a kind
of really I would imagine quite
irritating certainly some of the
teachers
um attention seeker so I think it all
happened around then
um and then it just sort of then
progressed
into University most of my twenties was
um
probably a lot of it was around you know
based around that uh and it was quite a
handy thing you know if you're going to
perform it takes care of that need to
just sort of you know just kind of
impress I think it was probably a a good
thing were you
picked on ortized or anything in school
before that point no so because I think
because my dad taught there it helped
but I was I was definitely always chosen
last for the teams and and things hated
uh
Sports and so on there were a couple of
kids that were probably I mean generally
fairly nasty anyway but I certainly got
uh
a a bit from them but no I think I think
I sort of did all right I think I
generally didn't enjoy school that much
and I felt like I was sort of um I said
intimidated but I don't I don't really
remember ever getting sort of I never
got beaten up or bullied or no one was
making my life particularly miserable I
think it was just the general feeling of
not quite fitting in
and religion I was incredibly religious
well yeah and then I hosted it at about
18 became incredibly atheist yeah and
you I read a similar sort of Journey in
your story at six or something you'd
asked your parents if you could go to
Bible That's Right Mrs Whitaker one of
our teachers at school was uh I really
liked a lot and um she
ran it was called Crusader class but
it's basically like a Sunday school
thing
um and uh because I was six and she
asked me if I wanted to go to it and I
just sort of Presumed every Everybody
did I didn't know any different so I
said to uh I asked my parents if I could
go and they said yes of course so I did
and by the time I realized that oh no
this is actually like a a thing that I
now believe in it was sort of I was
pretty much inculcated so it was uh hard
to step out of it but I did eventually
at University
so many years later I uh
through doing hypnosis first and magic
and they always give you quite a
skeptical outlook on things because you
just see how
people fool themselves and and so you
sort of naturally start to view
a lot of belief systems I think through
those eyes including your own I don't
know how it was for you but I
um and also the very idea of doing
hypnosis
um
I just remember that was because I was a
member of the Christian union in my
first year at University I went to
Bristol and they were just totally up in
arms I had I had um
members of the that Christian union at
the back of one of my shows exorcizing
me and casting out demons whilst I was
hypnotizing people on stage so again all
of that just sort of uh made me quite
just help with the sort of General
skepticism and it took a little while to
properly come out of it in fact that the
Richard Dawkins book The The God
Delusion came out around the time
that I had sort of mentally made that
step but didn't quite maybe have the
sort of proper language for it so that
was if that was a helpful book actually
I'm sure it was for many people in terms
of giving that lack of belief a kind of
a structure it was for me one of the
very sort of pivotal books in my life
when I when I was about 18 years old
um I also a bit about like compulsive
behaviors from your childhood things
like knocking your knees together and
yeah a series of other things really
Twitchy yeah a little on that sort of
kind of Tourette's sort of
scale I think there's a there's a
there's a wedge that ends with
um quite severe things but a lot a lot
of people have that experience of
um making a little funny tickly noises
in the throat or
having to you know not step on the
cracks and uh there's all the kind of
OCD thing that that starts to get
accompanied by feelings of dread and so
much I never had that but yeah I was
twitching I I find a lot of
um
kind of creative
Creative Kids are don't I don't really
know what what it is it's a it's a seems
to be a form of Auto suggestion
um
it's like when you get you get the idea
in your head and then it's very hard to
let it go and sometimes I I get it now
sometimes I get it on stage because
there's a certain amount there's a lot
of muscle memory with doing a stage show
so if you if something if a little
twitch you think is crept in at one
point during the show it'll just creep
in every night
um so I still kind of uh
still aware of it
um
a little more over the last few years
because obviously it's been such a you
know weird few years for everyone's
mental health so I've noticed it more
than I had before
um
but uh yeah and it was quite it was a it
was a lot my parents were quite
despairing with it I think it's a very
painful thing to watch should child do
and not know what were they watching how
to help
knees knocking sniffing terrible
sniffing yeah like Rip but really really
loud I went to see a um Alfred brendel
The Pianist playing in Berlin once when
I was uh studying out there I think or
did my Gap year I think it was out there
and just I mean
this guy's playing the I think it was
the Beethoven piano sonatas just him on
his own on the stage at the Berlin
Philharmonic
and there's this
incredibly loud sniffing that I'm doing
and by the second half everybody had
cleared out I was just basically a whole
empty area of the audience but yeah just
it's such a bizarre thing
um you just can't really stop it with
the best one in the world you can't stop
yourself from doing this there's these
things and it's um
and you also you don't have the language
for it as a kid that's that's the worst
part of it you don't have the language
to explain that it's a compulsion it you
sort of feel like you're in control of
it you say you feel like therefore the
only thing you can say is that you want
to do it if you don't want to do it
because it's
horrible you'd really really want to
stop and it's it's hard and frightening
because you can't articulate it and it
um
uh and I I think there's no answer to it
I think just it sort of passes as you've
um as you've matured
has your perspective of your childhood
evolved because I've found that mine
certainly has it's almost like with with
a bit more wisdom I say that I'm 30
years old now but with a little bit more
wisdom I've I've kind of have a
different perspective now on the events
of my childhood at one point I would
have kind of narrated them differently
but now I see different sort of truths
and through lines
in my early experience
I think I'm quite fond of my memories of
myself as a child
and I
um
it felt like there was quite a clean
break once I sort of went off to
University it felt like
life sort of stopped and started again
so I
when I think back to my kind of
um the sort of story of myself that I
guess I'm sort of quietly living out the
back of my head I sort of don't really
go much Beyond
uh University age
um and I'll happily find anything
excruciating like you know
more than you know anything I've said or
done 10 minutes ago I find that quite
easy
um and that feeling
I suppose kind of
gets weaker and weaker the further I go
back in terms of finding myself you know
embarrassing I and then by the time I
get to Childhood it's all perfectly or
feels
fine I mean I'm aware as I said that I
was kind of
would sort of just get on with my own
things but nothing I I
uh
I think I was sensitive I think I still
am I was quite a sensitive child I used
to I did used to cry a lot I know that
makes me sound
unhappy but I I used to it didn't take
much to make me
cry
um
and
I think I probably retained a sort of
uh sensitivity which is sort of
interesting so to write a lot about
stoicism and a lot of the things I think
people
you people do tend to write about the
things that you know that they
either need to learn for themselves or
our learning so you know you express
those things
um often better because you're
discovering them for free for yourself
um so uh
perhaps like a lot of
stoics I'm you know secretly quite uh
quite sensitive too so I remember that
but not not
um not really unhappy not not totally
blissfully happy either but just a kind
of Fairly content solitary kind of kid
that sensitivity
um
I've always wondered if if we're
particularly
taken by the Applause
are we therefore also taken by the
criticism
so people that don't end up committing
their lives to being like public
entertainers and living for the response
and the reaction that their work has are
those then also the people that are most
susceptible to
when you know the opposite of applause
uh
yeah I yes I guess so you're definitely
putting yourself out there aren't you if
you you perform and you thought you are
kind of you are um
opening yourself up to both extremes of
reactions but it wasn't really about
that for me I I um I think it was about
uh control was a big part of it and also
as a sort of
um like I didn't come out until I was
actually sort of quite late in my 30s
um and I think around the time that I
was getting into
the hypnosis that was you know sort of
University time really
uh
and I think
first of all it was this is all wasn't
clear to me at the time but with
hindsight that the control aspect of it
was very
um
clear uh and actually ticked well if you
watch a hypnotist hypnotizing people I
mean it's just that the whole thing is a
big exercise in in control and I think
I've sort of that was appealing to me
although I didn't know it I didn't it
didn't strike me quite in that language
at the time but I think looking back
um that was
helpful
um and also I think if the old um
outmoded cliche of the
the gay man in particular being you know
a hairdresser or a interior designer and
all of those sort of horrible old
cliches what they have in common
actors as well is the um the notion of
being able to create dazzling surfaces
because they they deflect people from
the more difficult but if you're feeling
Shame about you know what's underneath
um and I think Magic's very good for
that as well you know you're you're sort
of creating this bubble around yourself
this sort of this
um you're literally hiding behind
a trick and people will look at that
trick and go oh gosh you're amazing how
do you do that you're amazing that's a
very appealing thing a lot of kids get
into magic because they're
underconfident
um and a lot of people even going
through magic into adults they they've
learned to rely on that to impress
people and haven't had to go back and
just work through normal social skills
that most people do so it's it's a very
appealing
thing I think all of that was all of
that was helpful to me as somebody that
was
not out and you know kind of
working all that stuff out use the word
shame there it reminded me of listening
to your audiobook where you talk about
those two kids beating you up in your
sleeping bag I can't remember them oh
yeah yeah that's right yeah and one of
the lines you said in that section of
the book is that you were very good at I
think you said embodying shame but I
know that's not the exact word you used
but they were very good at liking
holding shame you're full of shame I
think was the the um
the message
yeah I I can't remember exactly what I
wrote but
um
yeah kind of it creeps up on you I said
I I find now it's um yeah I can ease I'm
prone to it you know if I feel I've
uh
upset my partner I'll it's it's a shame
that I'll go to rather than
defensiveness or you know yeah I just
I'll easily
I can easily get back to a feeling of
like oh I've you know I've been bad I've
just sort of let this person down
is that what does shame mean to you
because I think I've been using the word
a little bit without
um a very focused definition I've been
saying that I felt a lot of shame
because I was the only like black hidden
in all white school and we were the
poorest family and so that feeling of
Shame turned into like a motivation
which made me want to become a happy
sexy millionaire but what does shame
mean to you in that context
well I suppose if you distinguish it
from embarrassment embarrassment is sort
of where you sort of you've let yourself
down in front of or you've
it's it's a feeling you're going to get
from other people they're they're
important in that it's how you've
appeared before them or as I suppose
shame as how you've appeared before
yourself that you've sort of let
something down within yourself it's that
isn't it um
uh
but I think the experience of it is just
a sort of
um
it just becomes an easy resting place
whatever it is but it might be someone
else it could be
anger or Fury or whatever if there's
just a an emotional through line that
you've that was a familiar place when
you were young it's just you just find
yourself settling back into that and I
suppose part of
getting older is recognizing those kind
of things aren't they recognizing Ah
that's that is a you know a needless
pattern and as you said with your own
experience with that can those things
can be really helpful they can provide a
real
impetus and a motivation to um you know
to do things you wouldn't if I mean like
not not being out
all that energy was going into creating
this Mr Magic kind of
Persona and I just you know and although
it's easy to say you know you should
always always come out and all the rest
of it and of course those things are
important too but I don't think I'd be I
wouldn't be sitting here talking to you
now I don't think if if that had been an
easy ride you know um
shame being a
a familiar resting place as you kind of
describe it and you said that kind of
starts in your childhood I just want to
be because I want to make sure that I'm
clear on the context here that that has
a familiar sort of
um history in your childhood because of
the social dynamics of your childhood
because you felt like a bit different
and a bit like a loner is that what
you're saying or is there other Dynamics
with parents where they I know I think
specifically with sort of
the the gay thing I think I think I
think that's what it is I think if you
feel and hopefully it's different now
it's just you know it's just going back
a bit I'm 51 now so but if you
feel like those things are just
embarrassing and awkward you're kind of
you know it's not like you really get to
well you're finding it out in real time
about yourself aren't you so there's
just
uh it becomes an uncomfortable
Center of everything that starts to
affect so much of what happens on the
surface and there's a real experience I
think if you're not out which I've
recognized in many friends as well but
there's a bit of just a bit of a bubble
around you because you're sort of you're
having to maintain a kind of a
um a sort of curated exterior and and
part of that then is then what's
happening underneath is is uncomfortable
and difficult and feels
shameful um so I think that's it I think
that's where I don't remember feeling
that as a kid as I said quiet and so on
but I don't remember feeling that as an
experience but it just sort of
just kind of crept in and the more
the more I sort of um
uh
kind of
was leaning into the magic Persona thing
the more the more the outside becomes
sort of you know the the harder and more
sort of um uh opaque this sort of
exterior presentation becomes I think
the it goes hand in hand with a more
shameful
interior until in the end you just sort
of oh [ __ ] that and just sort of let it
all be fine
was was there a point and this might be
a really naive question as a straight
guy but was there a point where it
became crystal clear to you that your
your sexual preference was different or
was it slow sort of realizations and
yeah it was cut um if
it's sort of because you can never
really climb into anyone else's head
yeah and sort of understand what their
experience is it's it's it's sort of
um
it's often difficult to really know and
of course at the time I was also a
proper Christian
um which uh
slightly kind of messes the thing up and
just slightly gets in the way of the
whole thing I had a friend who went
through the um
some of that kind of uh Living Waters
movement which is the kind of gay
conversion it's got called Gay
conversion therapy it was a bit more
subtle than that but nonetheless is
basically that so he was going through
that and although I didn't I was kind of
um skirted it a little bit because I was
his friend and you know it was something
we were talking about a lot
um so all of those things
an obviously by the way it doesn't work
just in case I was wondering
um I mean I went in straight it worked
for me
um uh so yeah it was sort of um
I don't know I don't there's never just
a clear moment it's just uh I think as I
just got in the public eye I thought I
don't want this to be some weird sort of
thing that's like a secret
um so uh
and then you come out of it and you come
out about it and then actually the uh
the The Joy the reason why it's
liberating at least it was for me and
probably hopefully most people now is
that people just don't care like this
thing that you've carried around and
that experience that shameful Center
that's there again shame is a really
strong word but nonetheless it is kind
of
just this sort of awkward thing and
eventually
when it when you sort of
are open about it it's just people don't
care why why would they care so that's
that's the lib that's why it's
liberating it's not because suddenly you
can you know spin around in the street
with your shopping bags it's um it's
just that oh no one cares about
you're driving difficult private stuff
in the best way so actually and you've
done the big one like you've so now
anything else after this will be will be
fine that I think that's why it's a
liberating thing I really quite I think
it was in the telegraph well you'd said
that um maybe the journalist was
commentating that um something as simple
as mislaying your keys can
trigger a whole new wave of self-hatred
oh God
that was me saying that was it uh yeah
that's just Fury though isn't it when
you can't find a circle you can't find
your keys or your pen
um self-hatred I mean is a strong strong
word uh
I think the people maybe yeah maybe it
does yeah I probably would yes I would
reflect it back on myself rather than
being angry
my partner anybody else who's probably
lost it that's what he'd do he'd be
angry that I I must have put his keys
somewhere because he can't find them I
would just be yeah beating myself up for
why am I always losing stuff why can't I
remember where I put things yeah I
definitely would do that
interesting I wouldn't no no it wouldn't
I don't think it would reflect on my my
own self-image if I lost the keys
or even if it did it wouldn't negatively
reflect I think that's just who I am
that's who I am yeah I'm one organized
versus like oh I'm so inaugurated I hate
that about myself
yeah well I don't know when I said that
that was probably quite a while ago and
uh I don't know if I'd necessarily be
that hard on myself now plus unless you
exaggerate these things for rhetorical
effect
um has anything changed like on a really
fundamental level yeah I'm so curious
about how
how how could we are actually changing
some of these things because we say yeah
we talk about it but as I've got an
older and older and as I've done more
and more of these interviews I tend to
find that they're like real fundamental
stuff is never healed it never goes away
and I actually think that's really good
news for people because there's a lot of
people that are trying to sell you on
this [ __ ] that they can take your
traumas or your your insecurities to
zero yeah I've never seen it happen no
that's all wrong and even even stoicism
in a way is sort of um
a little guilty of that
um even something that's talked about
talking about rolling with the punches
of life is still kind of suggesting that
and if you get this right you won't be
disturbed you know you won't experience
anxiety that is all that's a little bit
off really I think the nature of life is
that it is
it is difficult and uh not all the time
but a lot of the time things really go
badly and they certainly don't go as you
planned and you know that you actually
as you start to get older you realize
your plans probably have nothing to do
with how things are turning out but the
illusion that they are is what propels
you through the first half of life
um
so uh
actually I think the project the task
our task is
um
a certain amount of is sort of personal
development and in integrating ourselves
with the parts of us that we are
uncomfortable with
so again that's the project of relating
to what's difficult within ourselves and
then how we do that in life as well how
we relate to things that are difficult
and tricky in life because the thing
about although that experience can be
very
um
isolating those feelings of you know
when life
lets you down or you feel you've failed
they tend to be quite isolating
experiences
um like shame right that's a very
isolating thing whereas actually and
weirdly this I'm doing this show showing
at the moment and this is entirely what
the show's about
those isolating experiences like they're
exactly the things that join us all up
that is the
that is The Human Experience how how do
we deal with the difficulties of life
you know when things
are going badly and we feel like we fail
that's that's
what we all have to find our way through
so the things that feel most isolating
are the things that tend to connect us
um so I don't think it's about trying to
bury them under sort of
you know some sort of forced optimism
and it isn't about reaching a Nirvana of
of um
a problem-free life I think that's uh
it's a really sort of terrible
project because you're going to end up
blaming yourself for failing you weren't
a good enough stoic or you weren't a
good enough Optimist or whatever
um always reminded me of the faith
healers that I um
spent a lot of time watching and when
they do that thing of saying throw away
your pills and if your illness returns
it's because you didn't have enough
Faith like it's your fault
and that's no different from the you
know the the secret you know the um the
Law of Attraction this is yeah it's the
same thing it's the same thing you have
to completely commit yourself and if it
doesn't work out if the universe doesn't
provide you with it's always jewelry and
money and cars a bit odd
um then you didn't have enough Faith um
it wasn't you know it was your own fault
um so it's a perfect cycle of uh blame
um uh which exonerates the um
the actual system completely inputs the
blame uh entirely on on you so I'm yeah
I uh there's a bit of an irony in the
fact that people choose those books
because they they don't want
responsibility but failure puts
responsibility back on them because I
think of like the the law of attract I
actually had a conversation with um a
girl I was dating many years ago in New
York and she actually got out the cab
and walked off because I said to her
that I she believed that she could
visualize anything into existence I went
so you believe that you can just think
about something and then it will happen
so you could think about becoming a
billionaire and what happened she went
yes I was like no I don't agree with
that but house because you put out into
the universe and then it comes back and
what they're doing in that to me it
seems like
they're alleviating their own sense of
responsibility they're putting it up to
the puppet master in the universe but as
you've described then when that fails
the blame is ultimately on them for not
doing it yeah it must be awful as
opposed to it was just a bad idea to to
begin with and more helpfully
how do we live comfortably with the
universe that doesn't give a [ __ ] what
we what our plans are well why would it
doesn't make any sense so how do we how
do we navigate and that there's a there
is an ancient
uh sort of
image it's it's appeared in so many
different forms of an x equals y
diagonal so if you imagine a graph and
you've got along one axis you've got the
x-axis is the stuff you want to achieve
in life your aims and your plans and
then the other access the y-axis is just
life what they used to call Fortune it's
all the stuff that just gets thrown at
you
um
if you imagine the line that we lead in
our in our lives it's a sort of an x
equals y line right it's sort of an
undulating line so sometimes our plans
are winning and we're doing great and
sometimes life's throwing stuff back at
us we have no control over and things
are gone horrible and someone's got ill
or whatever it is so there's this sort
of undulating x equals y diagonal where
we're being pulled in these two
different directions that's what we live
that's just sort of reality and the
nature of the kind of the American
optimistic model is that by believing in
ourselves
weaken and this is not it's an old
hangover from protestantism um the sort
of work ethic that you can by believing
in yourself you can crank that line up
so it's in line with your aims and your
goals
um and
we just it's it's a we've completely
obliterated the idea of just fortune and
life from that you know we used to
we used to call people um
unfortunate now we call them losers you
know so there's a there's a a lack of
respect now for just the fact that life
is throwing stuff back at you so how do
you how do you navigate that I think
actually stoicism is a very good toolkit
foreign
pretty much all of your listeners will
be familiar with but the the bottom line
of it is
is that you know the the the things in
life it's not the things in life that
cause your problems it's the the story
that you tell yourself about them it's
the judgments that you make about them
which is a very good and sensible idea
that's made its way down to us
um over the last couple of thousand
years and then Allied to that
you take all the stuff you have no
control over
outcomes what other people do and what
they think and so on and you can just
decide that that stuff is fine as it is
and you can just focus on the stuff only
try and change the stuff you can
actually change which is the world of
your own thoughts and your own actions
and that's where we should put our
attention and then there's interesting
there is a middle ground
of uh you know like if you're well
success of any sort you know there's
parts of that you're in control of and
parts that you're not so it's like a
best analogy I've read for is like going
into a game of tennis if you go in
determined to win and then your uh your
opponent is playing better than you
you're probably going to get anxious and
you're going to feel that you're failing
whereas if you go in determined to play
as well as you can again just to control
the part you're in you're in charge of
then uh it sort of doesn't matter if
your opponents
a bit better than you or they start to
win you're not you're not failing you
know you're and the same goes for
um
you know the stomachs were big movers
and shakers you if you want to change
the world you can but you're only gonna
emotionally commit yourself to your
intention and your actions not the
outcomes which may happen a generation
after you've after you've died you know
that's something out of your hands I
think all that's very helpful and very
useful the only thing if you see it as a
toolkit
um to be lent into when it's helpful but
the uh even that uh if you take it as a
sort of a you know almost like a
spiritual way of life
can fall into the um problem of and
therefore we shouldn't have any anxiety
therefore anxiety is still somehow
the demon but you know without anxiety
how do you know to change anything in
your life how do you know to change your
job unless the current job is making you
feel bad or you know things have to
become anxious and things have to fall
away in order for us to move forward and
grow and we you know you can't do that
without embracing anxiety to to an
extent
as I've aged I've started to realize
that the kind of compass of my life is
how I feel and that's kind of what
you've alluded to there that we have
this signal sometimes it comes in the
form of anxiety sometimes it comes in
the form of fear but these are all like
really useful signals
um do you resonate with what I just said
there in terms of like feelings that our
body is giving us are the greatest
signals for uh for us to navigate versus
like narratives versus like what my mum
wants or I end up in a working in the
city in like a suit and a tie because
that's what Society had an expectation
of but I'm feeling a signal inside which
is I know depression or I'm feeling you
know I think those things are very
important to listen to I think we we do
live out stories very easily we do tend
to
uh see things in terms of a narrative
and that's
um it's an interestingly double-edged
thing because on the one hand
whether you know someone's written in or
out of a story it's become very
important language and harm and all of
those things have all got suddenly very
tied up and store the very notion of
story has become
so important um taking authorship of
your story and so on but the other the
other side of that which you know I live
out in my in my job as a magician is
that stories are just
stories you know if a magician fools you
with a trick in a way that works you
what you're being shown is that your
story that you're performing with the
world isn't quite right like there's
something you missed and you always feel
like you properly paid attention you saw
everything you you were taking in all
the information
but it shows you that you've missed
something that your Narrative of what
reality is isn't the same as the world
um
and uh
so that the
the story side of things it seems to be
part of just our makeup but it's
important not to
fall in love with it too much and to
realize that the nature of a story is
that it there's stuff you're excluding
there's an image isn't there of telling
a story over
a campfire and a clearing and it's cozy
um but then there's all the forest in
the darkness with all the stuff that
you're
uh excluding from that story and that's
where the monsters live and the nature
of monsters that they come and bite you
and all the stuff that we don't include
in a story whether it's the story we
tell about uh tell ourselves about
ourselves
um or whether it's a story We Tell
ourselves about are
Nation or our culture whether it's a
social thing or whether it's a private
thing the stuff that we
bury and the stuff that we don't include
within the narrative
because the narrative is really too
simple
is
goes deep like it's getting sort of gets
buried it gets buried in our own
unconscious or it gets buried in the
untold story of whatever the thing is
and that's what comes back and bites us
that's the the stuff that comes to own
us in our own lives and
and in our uh you know in our
societal lives as well as the stuff that
we've buried and I think as you as you
get older this is where that
those feeling signals come in I think it
becomes more and more important to pay
attention to the things that we are
banishing from our stories you know what
what do we
if we think about what makes us feel
resentful or what we Envy or you know
what are what are those things because
those are the things that we're bearing
somehow and I think
there's a shift in the second half of
life and a membership I'm a chunk older
than you but um where
we can disengage a bit with the
the story that we've been telling of how
to move forward in life that's all about
a dialogue with the
external world that's where we're
getting our cues from people showing us
what we need to be successful what we
need to look or act in a certain way
that denotes moving forward in progress
we do that for the first half of life
and it is sustained a little by this
optimistic illusion that the child the
castles that we're chasing in the air
that will reach if we just you know a
lot of Happiness deferring going on and
a lot of you know focusing on the future
and then something happens around
midlife where actually the project
shifts to
taking the cues from within rather than
from the outside world and I think then
that's a good time for priorities to
shift from what will
give me success in the future to what is
actually what might bring pleasure and
satisfaction and meaning
now in the in the present I think that's
a useful thing to lean into towards the
second half of life
it was University that's
um sort of sparked your interest in
hypnosis right yeah yeah yeah you saw
someone on campus doing Martin Taylor
was doing a show yes it was in my
freshers week and uh wow that was
amazing and I I left and walked back
that night with a friend and said I'm
going to learn how to do this and my
friend Nick said oh yeah so am I but I
knew I meant it I knew that I've never
seen it before never come across
hypnosis I obviously heard of it but
um and it was a good show like it wasn't
you know embarrassing people are making
them look stupid it was sort of just
jaw-dropping
um how did you know that you meant it
because I've had that feeling in my life
before where something just connects
yeah well I think it was the again those
boxes were being ticked something about
performing something about control
uh
I didn't really know it it just felt
like I want I I have to do that it's the
most amazing thing I've seen and it was
uh
it was appealing in ways that just
weren't really um I suppose I hadn't
really
thought about I hadn't thought about
performing hadn't uh
but yeah I think I think that's what's
happening isn't it there's something
it's resonating unconsciously it's
something that you kind of need
and it was absolutely no there was no
doubt so I I bought borrowed stole any
books I could find on the subject you
probably just learn on YouTube nowadays
but it's probably a dodgy thing because
you need to
you need to learn it the long way around
so that if you run into problems or if
someone's having a weird time when
you're hypnotizing them you can't be
like fumbling around trying to Google
what to do you know you need to have the
skills there and the wherewithal to
to deal with it so I definitely learned
the long way around uh
yeah
and then
you became I think from what I was
reading pretty obsessed with magic and
hypnosis and yeah to the point that you
have a conversation with your parents
and you tell them that you're gonna yeah
I remember saying to my mum I think I'm
not going to be a lawyer I was studying
uh law in German I said I'm not going to
be a lawyer I'm going to be a um a
magician I said oh fine that sounds
great sounds much more fun which
actually made me stop and think okay
hang on probably being a bit probably
being a bit rash
um what did they say so they were
okay with it totally yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what she said she said oh that
sounds great it sounds much more fun
it's nice isn't it I wrote them a letter
at the end of my first year saying
because I I saw all these other
law students really fretting about their
exams because of what their parents were
going to think if they didn't pass and
that had never occurred to me as a thing
that your parents would make you feel so
I uh wrote them a letter thanking them
for
for that just for
um
letting me always do what I
wanted to do the only thing they ever
put any pressure on me to do is learn
how to drive and I don't drive
I still don't drive that's still that
drive
it's it's quite a common story I have to
say that um
your obsession seemed to come from
or at least be driven by
some kind of insecurity
as in like the reason why hypnosis
initially resonated so much was because
it was
giving you some it felt like it might
offer you something that you were
looking for or didn't have yourself yeah
that's a story I hear also obsessions
are though isn't that the nature of them
aren't your eyes it's just that the
level of obsession I saw when from that
day when you discovered hypnosis like
getting all the books teaching yourself
yeah and then even Beyond University
where you start working in restaurants
for many many years how long how long
from that first day when you saw
hypnosis for the first time until
um let's say before you the TV stuff
began how long is that sort of tenure
I think the tenure is about is about 10
years 10 years I think so let me think
so I I graduated 94 and then uh by that
point I was doing the odd um hypnosis
show
for students I
oh actually the the first TV show went
out in December 2000. so I was into all
it was about 10 years but also included
my University career but there was a
six-year period after University by
which point I was already doing it
mainly for students when I was just then
signing on or just about scraping a
living
doing hypnosis shows but a lot more
magic I was doing magic in restaurants
in Bristol and then people would book me
for their parties and
um
and I wrote a book for magicians which
kind of got me known within that world
which that then led to
um being picked out for a TV show that
led to me getting a phone call
my name getting passed around in that
world so that's almost 10 years of
practicing yeah
um without real any real money when you
say signing on for people that are in
America signing out as in welfare I
guess you'd call it yeah I was I was I
lived in this my student flat I stayed
in it was quite a nice
flat I had all my books in it and my
parrot and uh that didn't cost me very
much and I just loved his life I would
go out dreaming up magic tricks during
the day and then I would go out and do
them in the evening and so I developed
my own sort of approach to it all
and uh
that
yeah that I I just remember thinking
I've never had any ambition at all and
and I just remember thinking if I if I
can take us like a a cross section of my
life is everything in the right place
like am I I'd like to get up whenever
I'd like to get up I'd like to feel I
can make my own decisions
about what I do from day to day and I
just had a vague idea of those sorts of
things that were important to me and
um
and
if anything didn't feel right it'd be
easy to sort of change and that was all
that was always how I was never about
looking forward into the future it was
never about where do I want to be it was
just is this day this week sort of the
life that I'd like to be living and
that's never changed um I suppose the
difference is is you get
successful you start to have people
around you that are doing those other
jobs for you the grown-up jobs and you
know I've got a manager and I've worked
with producers and all that kind of
things so it's not like that doesn't
have to happen somewhere along the line
but it doesn't come from me I've
um
uh you can feel like a kid a little bit
a bit like a child in a world of
grown-ups so I feel that sometimes
except now the grown-ups are younger
than me which is uh strange
um but also I think maybe that's a good
way to feel maybe that's a nice way to
be if you can trust yourself from today
yeah to the to that young man in those
restaurants in Bristol doing the magic
tricks
is there a difference in your level of
happiness
I think about this
I I
I think it's about the same but it's
different I mean the the
um a bit like
being a kid and playing on my own most
of my twenties were cut well my twenties
were sort of Fairly fairly solitary as
well and that's another template that
settles in so
um that's again an easy place to go back
to I love my own company all my
interests the things I love doing
out of my job painting writing and
reading and they're all like solitary
things I said that's a comfortable place
for me so pardon me
slide more of that then so it slightly
misses that but actually that's you know
I also aware it was that was lonely
sometimes and
um you know I like being in a
relationship too so it's different had a
different feel about it
um
I think the freedom to just
do what I wanted to do and kind of um
create this sort of world for myself
that was kind of lovely and that's
harder to do that as you grow up and you
do have responsibilities and you know
you're contributing to a household and
you've got a partner you've got dogs and
all of that it's not not quite as easy
so a childish part of me would kind of
quite like going back to that but not
really not really I wouldn't really
press a button to make it happen it's
just a a nice little sort of back of the
head dream as we probably all
have maybe don't we a slight kind of
fantasy thing it would never really live
it out but it's just something nice
about
about that
um
it's almost like um I feel like you were
my head is like you know you're in
Bristol mining your own business
enjoying the the simple life and then
they pulled you they ripped you out of
Bristol
um you were really successful so they
put you on TV that was really successful
and sometimes when people are successful
they sometimes forget and I think I've
done this in my life a few times kind of
we forget to take the moment of pause
and consider how intentional this
journey and Direction and direction of
travel is kind of get pulled and dragged
and then ends up feeling a bit like
you're throwing the coal in the the
steam engine of the train just to keep
it moving has there ever been a moment
of pause in your life where you've
you've gone do you know what I need to
take some time and just think about what
I'm doing and why I'm doing it because
I've been successful and then I've
climbed the ladder people do that a lot
in the corporate world they become a
good lawyer then they get promoted then
they're a partner and they go [ __ ] am I
doing here yeah I think we drift towards
the things we're second best it's like
you know the the great teacher that
becomes a Headmaster but would have been
a better teacher than uh that's an easy
thing to do isn't it um and I think that
sometimes I think about oh it might be
quite nice to act I think I'm doing
exactly that thing of sort of going from
being
um
someone who's really good at what I do
now and I just to sort of why why would
I want to tell that might be fun but
like what a strange thing we naturally
start to drift towards things that we're
not as good at
um
uh I the only I would say when you said
that I was thinking of um the early the
Early TV shows
when I was sort of which were very much
a response to David Blaine's success in
the states I'm out doing you know mind
reading tricks and things and
I I kind of felt like I'd grown out of
it but I was that was sort of the mode
that I was caught in and I definitely
felt like I'm not really enjoying this
and that led to a shift in the type of
shows I was doing so the I mean the last
show I've done is on Netflix called
sacrifice if
people have no idea who I am and they've
listened this far
um uh and generally what I've been doing
for the last decade or so with the TV
shows is putting people through these
kind of Truman Show style big social
experiments often quite life or death
situations they found themselves in
without realizing they're part of a show
and what that allowed me to do was not
be the center of attention and the
reason the reason for it is actually
apart from just my own dissatisfaction
with it but just magically if you um if
you can click your fingers and make
anything happen
which is sort of what a magician does
dramatically that's a very um unsound
uh place to be and this is you know pet
and Teller the yeah yeah so something
that teller who apart from being a
beautiful magician is a wonderful
thinker
as well he's spoken a lot about this
that it's actually very bad drama if you
can make anything happen what we want
dramatically are heroes people that are
struggling with the situation maybe they
are trying to get to point a but
actually they end up at point B
um and his thoughts and my own sort of
sort of dissatisfaction I guess with
that first stage of my career led to
this shift where I could be in the
background pulling the strings but
actually you're watching a real member
of the public go through quite intense
drama and that has to be more appealing
than somebody going hey look at me
aren't I clever which is sort of the
bottom line of what most magic is so I
think that was a kind of
semi-deliberate
shift that came from a moment of pause
was it quite intentional for you to take
you know I've seen multiple
documentaries you've done where you're
proving that magic or the supernatural
isn't real and again that's super
compelling because we would expect you
to be leaning into that and persuading
us of the supernatural whereas some of
the most compelling stuff I've watched
you do whether you're confronting like a
psychic that's pretending to speak to
the dead or I remember that reading you
did where the woman had pulled up
outside of the Mercedes and the minute
on a mini yeah yeah and you would you
basically what was it you you um you
read her not her future you read into
her life I think it was that the psychic
that I was challenging had mentioned um
that she drove a little red mini and
she'd been really impressed by that but
actually I've seen him pull up his car
uh right parked next to her in the car
park yeah but actually I think it's the
opposite I think the um there's a long
tradition of magicians
pulling apart psychics and charlatans
and I think it's because we end up with
a knowledge of how those things work
um and it goes right back to
Houdini and the seances and exposing the
fraudulent mediums in the dark you know
it's a long a long and probably before
that but there's a long history of it
um so I the only thing about it is that
you're if you're just going no this is
fake you're not being very entertaining
and by the nature of what those people
do it's more entertaining so they've
kind of won the game so I've
tried to avoid
making
when I when I have sort of you know
attacked those areas rather than just
attack them and make it negative I've
always tried to recreate something and
make it more interesting and and better
while at the same time saying I'm not
really doing this so for example there
was a in one of the shows I did
I had an audience on stage this was in
Infamous which was a previous Stage Show
and I
um
was giving them mediumship readings
right so I say just come up if you've
lost somebody if there's somebody that
you would that you'd want to get in
touch with if you were to see a medium
and a skeptical audience kind of like me
right because they're my audiences but
so they'd come up and sit down and I
would start to give them these readings
and I would say and I'm getting a
message from your auntie Jill is that
right do you have an auntie Jill that
passed away that yes and she's saying
she's not saying anything I'm just
making this up but she's saying that
you've got oh you've got a little dog
called Bella that she really loves is
that right yes and um and I'm lying to
you but she said so I would like pepper
these like impossible information I was
giving with reminders that I was making
it up
um
and I just found that really really sort
of interesting and and um theatrically
it was really interesting and much more
interesting than saying these people are
fake and prove it and if you can prove
it I'll give you a million dollars
whatever so I've I've tried to find a
more creative approach to that do some
people think you are you are
Supernatural in your powers some well I
was going to say actually after that
about a week into that show I came out
there's a girl at stage door said
um I wondered if you could put me I say
girl which was you know you know in her
20s but if you could put me in touch
with my grandmother who's passed on and
I said oh God I'm so sorry I hoped it
was clear from the show that I can't
really do it that stuff isn't real and
she don't know I know I know you can't
really do it and it's not real but I
just wondered if you could just put me
in touch with her like it was
extraordinary
um
how we kind of can balance these things
in our in our heads so yeah I
I I'm sure people believe all sorts of
things about me I think the the way of
the way I look at it is a bell curve so
at one end of the bell curve it's people
that think it's all fake it's all
Stooges it's all set up
um and I never use Stooges and that's
not what it is and at The Other Extreme
people saying I'm psychic and I won't
admit to it which is also not true
um and then there's this main swell in
the Middle where people sort of get it
um and that's really all you can I think
take
uh responsibility for really there's
always going to be people at the far
edges that will have uh strange and
extreme reactions
um and then you know I think there's a
certain license on stage which is
different from
TV if you're doing stuff down the barrel
of a TV if you're talking to people at
home there's a level of directness and
honesty there whereas it feels like on
stage there's a kind of theatrical
quotation marks around the whole thing
so I feel like I do things on stage
which I wouldn't do on TV
um
so that changes it too it's quite an
interesting line sort of treading
treading that I kind of in the very
early shows very early TV shows it was
very much like I'm I am doing this for
real that's what I said this and these
are not tricks
um and then once the show's realized
once we realized there was going to be
some longevity and there were going to
be more shows it was important to me
just to
bring it back to a place that was honest
and kind of ambiguous as well and to and
I've enjoyed that now I like leaning
into the ambiguity ambiguity of what I'm
doing
because again it it
it means that you can do more
interesting stuff with it the you know
if there's a lesson in it about
how we see the world how
the story We Tell ourselves is not
what's real how we mistake that story
for reality you know we mistake the
limits of Our Own
um field of vision for the for the
horizons of the world you know if we if
there's something in there to be said
in something as childish as magic if
there's some something worthwhile to be
said it's much easier to say that if
you're not trying to make it about
yourself
has anything ever
stumped you in terms of the supernatural
I you know I was
your work is predominantly based in
Psychology right so has there have you
ever done anything and thought how the
[ __ ] did that happen
uh two things come to mind one I was in
a restaurant in Bristol
approaching a table which is always
excruciating
um
uh if people aren't interested
and I'm walking up with a deck of cards
and I sort of introduce myself and it's
two businessmen
and one of them says oh no no thank you
so much and I said okay and as I walked
away the other one went but Queen of
Hearts 13 cards down
and I sort of laughed and walked away
then went into a corner and counted the
guards down at the 13th one down was the
Queen of Hearts no idea how he did that
if you are listening please get in touch
that's bugged me for 20 years and the
um the other thing was actually doing I
did a show called Miracle which is so
this is also on Netflix it was a uh uh
previous uh stage show a few State shows
ago and the second half was healing it
was like Evangelical
uh healing people being slain in the
spirit and
um had no idea if it was going to work
because again very skeptical audience
like not you know if you I've been to
these events with these big big name
healers and of course people are
arriving expecting it to work and
they've got a certain amount of you know
uh Readiness for it which obviously
helps and I didn't know if it was going
to work at all but it did and again I'm
sort of undercutting it like I'm I'm
doing it and I'm creating these healings
and inverted commas for people in the
audience but at the same time I'm kind
of
undercutting it too but um
it was extraordinary I mean I remember
in the first week a woman came up and
she'd been parallel she was probably in
her 40s she'd been paralyzed on one side
of her body since she was four or
something in floods of Tears because she
could move her left arm for the first
time
um and night after night things like
that sometimes as I imagine just you
know someone people with a bad back that
felt better but sometimes really quite
dramatic things too
and it was
although I could explain it because I
knew what I was doing
it was
um
what what you're seeing is the
psychological component of suffering
right like if you take an x-ray before
and after nothing's happened nothing's
changed but that how that person is
living out their
um
Affliction how they live their
relationship to their suffering has
that's been made to change
so what you're
seeing it's just a mix of two things
that are going on there's certain
there's adrenaline which is a natural
painkiller so you make that you make the
whole experience full of adrenaline
um you know in the same way of a you
know lion walked into this room and
you'd previously stubbed your toe you'd
run away and you wouldn't feel the pain
of your toe right because there's a
bigger threat
um that's just adrenaline that's fine
and then but this other thing that which
is maybe kick-started by the experience
of the adrenaline that you you've this
thing that you've lived out
like presumably this woman
her arm had been fine for many years but
she hadn't she just continued to live as
if it wasn't you know and all the stuff
that you build up around pain you know
the the way people respond to you so you
there's a whole network of
um social aspects to it over protecting
something that doesn't need protecting
anymore you know it's much more
complicated than simply the organic
cause of of um of your pain there's lots
of other things that sustain it and can
keep it going Beyond really where it's
useful so there she was having this
extraordinary experience she couldn't
explain
um
when really nothing had happened Beyond
she was just had been snapped out of
something that was that was
sort of amazing and kind of wonderful
that I started to you know do the thing
of going maybe I could do this maybe I
could offer this as a show of like
secular healing it'll only work on some
people and you're only dealing with
relatively small percentages
um
and I did start to think that and of
course that's where you start to go mad
that's when you start to think you're
playing God and and then of course
people because I when you go to these
events the big name healers I've seen
Benny Hinn and others
um what you what you don't really see
when you watch those things on TV is
that there are
in some of these big venues hospital
beds that have been brought in there are
people with you know a kid with Down
Syndrome that I spoke to the mum and
she'd she'd taken her son to so many
shows following around the country
um and things that just they're not
going to get they're not going to get
healed by those kind of
Dynamics
um so that's an uglier sort of side of
that because people have become very
dependent on it are not going to get any
help and then there's the lack of any
sort of
follow-up you know there's plenty of
infrastructure in place if you want to
donate but no infrastructure if you've
been in any way adversely affected by it
and you want help or if you've had a
healing and now you you'll don't know
how to sustain that or what you're
supposed to do other than being told to
give more money you know you know when
um people discovered through your TV
work that you had this
skill and talent
I imagine you've got lots of approaches
to use it for Less ethical reasons
because I I mean help me get the
girlfriend back help me close the deal
or help me rob a bank
a little not um I suppose people would
have to ask that wouldn't have the the
only I I remember I've been asked by the
FBI I've been asked by the police really
to help I mean it's never gone beyond
that discussion because I just I mean
even you know there's plenty of
businesses as well but it's just it's
not my world I feel like a
I'm an Entertainer I'm also quite
um
introverted I don't quite have that
thing of like
you know yeah let me get out there and
and
a change the world or B I don't have to
whatever that thing is that I feel I
could just apply this to would it be
anyone everything or the police went out
I don't know because it never went
beyond them saying would you come and
talk to us about something and us
getting back and saying
no it's not appropriate so I don't know
now I want to know
I had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so has my diet and
right now I'm just going to be
completely honest with you I'm starting
to think a lot about slimming down a
little bit because over the last couple
of probably the last four or five months
my diet has been pretty bad
um and it started to show a little bit
really over the last two months I go to
the gym about 80 of the time so I track
it with 10 of my friends in a WhatsApp
group and this tracker online and I'm
currently at 81
um so 81 of the days I've done a workout
in the last 150 days right so I'm going
to the gym about six times a week and so
one of the things I'm doing now to
reduce my calorie intake and trying to
get back to being nutritionally complete
and all I eat is I'm having the fuel
protein shake thank you heal for making
a product that I actually like The
Salted Caramel is my favorite I've got
the banana one here which is the one my
girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is the one we are lucky enough
to have Intel sponsoring this podcast
and in previous episode AIDS I've
introduced the Intel Evo platform the
badge of approval for high spec laptops
that will enable you to be more
productive on the go all of their
designs are tested to make sure they're
extremely thin and making them super
portable and they also have a high
quality display and camera features for
example this Samsung device that I'm
using for those of you that are watching
on on YouTube or Spotify is super light
making it the perfect on-the-go device
whether I'm working in a plane or I'm in
the car or wherever I am on the go with
Intel Evo you don't need to sacrifice
you get the performance you need but in
a stylish and lightweight design so now
you know all you need to do is to look
for the Intel Evo badge to be assured of
performance and as always to find out
more head to intel.co.uk Evo your skill
stack when I think about the you know
because there's lots of people that
might have studied hypnosis or they
might have studied magic or sleight of
hand or whatever but they didn't end up
on
the level you're on at the table you're
at on the shows you're on when you think
about why you got there I understand
that 10 years of
The graft and I see that in a lot of
people that sit here I see it in Jimmy
Carr leaves University goes and does all
of these like [ __ ] gigs for 20 quid for
years on years and years and years I see
it Lewis Capaldi the musician who went
and played in pubs in Scotland for years
and years and years and years and just
absolutely loved it wanted to stay there
I see the tenure bit which a lot of
young kids don't appreciate because we
all want it now and we want it for the
wrong reasons
but what else was it about you the way
your delivery your style that you think
in hindsight made you
compelling
oh it's a really difficult one it's
difficult it's difficult even if I knew
the answer would be hard to say it
um I I think
I don't think it's that I think it's
sort of it's not quite that intentional
I think you've probably grafted and done
those things I can't speak for Jimmy and
others but probably just because you
really enjoyed them in and of themselves
you probably weren't thinking I don't do
this if I get ahead I can secure this
for myself probably and if that is the
case if you are just doing it because
you love it
and that feels like in and of itself
what you're doing and there's no
particular need for a plan beyond that
then you'll keep at it you'll get very
you'll get very good at it if if that's
if that feels like all you need in the
moment anyway then why why wouldn't you
you know love it and put your all your
passion into it and get very good at it
so that helped
um
uh
and then when things did sort of take
off a bit my manager also had a similar
um ethos of just sort of Slow Burn Slow
Burn there was never any sense of me you
know being thrown at a public or any
sort of overnight success or anything
like that it was a very deliberate thing
it just slowly kind of letting it get
out there and that so that was helpful
um I think as I've I had a good team
around me
um it's not like a one not really a
one-man thing there's always although I
had had my own experience for those 10
years of doing it on my own once I got
into the TV there was like a little
group of us which I'm sure is fairly
common
and then
I think I think what does help is
letting it grow up with me as I've as
I've got older I've just let the thing
develop with me like I don't really know
what job to you know you asked me before
we started like how I'd refer to myself
I never really know I mean Mentalist I
think technically it's what I am but I
mean
I remember a couple of years ago I had
the book on happy happiness come out
which is essentially a book of Greek
philosophy come out the sake the same
month as a ghost trainer for the thought
Park and I do remember thinking I don't
know what I don't know what that is I
don't know what job that is that allows
for those two things it certainly isn't
mentalism
um so um uh so yeah just allowing
allowing the thing to grow up with me
and in terms of like you know I
occasionally you know people talk about
the brand and so on it's it's um
it's a very helpful thing I think just
let it let the thing just be you
and not
particularly be driven by the
limitations of what
it when I first started I remember
reading I used to go on them magic
discussion forums and so on to see what
magicians were saying about me and there
was a lot of like oh this isn't even
mentalism like there's a certain type of
magic called mentalism and I wasn't
quite doing that I was doing stuff that
wasn't 10 and they would they would see
that as a real sort of negative and I
always thought that's
why that's interesting that that would
bother anybody a who knows what the word
even means who cares and B that that
would that I wasn't somehow sticking
within that
um so and that's another thing about
playing on your own isn't it and um you
you
or being if you if you feel like an
outsider as a kid I think as you get
older you start you value that that
becomes like a bit of a superpower you
you hang on to that feeling of
of um
being an outsider and you kind of use
that so that's always helped me and I've
just followed my
nose for what feels fun and interesting
and worthwhile and as I've got older
I've let those things grow with me and
um I find a lot of Life much more
interesting than magic Magic's quite a
childish thing really so
it means that the stuff I find more
interesting about life I can bring into
magic you know I think if you've got if
you've got both feet in your
craft or your art form or whatever if as
in if the thing is feels to you so huge
and expansive and all that you know you
can't you're sort of a bit overwhelmed
by it you can't move it anywhere so if
you've got one foot in that thing and
your other foot in the rest of Life at
least you've got some leverage then to
take this thing that you do somewhere
interesting so maybe that's helped as
well I see that in your shows I see how
your other passions are riddled
throughout the show I remember watching
a show in New York which was just
astounding it's funny because I think of
myself as a smart person you know I
think I'll figure this out I'll he won't
be able to
um make me look the other way or he
won't be able to control my narrative he
won't be able to get me and every single
time I've been to a shows in London New
York they're all just I leave in silence
yeah like because you're right that like
misdirection where you've got me
thinking this thing yeah and then I go
what the hell like it's this constant
like disappointment with myself that I'm
not as smart as I think I am oh that's
so nice it's always like what can I
there's you know 2 000 people trapped in
a room with me what can I what can I do
with them it's always it's a lovely
feeling to start with and that the
section on when you have the painting I
don't want to give anything away the
painting is this in the show that you
saw in New York I believe it was New
York I've seen I've been to two London
and New York one with my family in
London which was many years ago about
four probably I'd say four or five maybe
five years ago yeah and then the one in
New York I think was
was it wasn't pre-pandemic it couldn't
have been yeah it was just before the
pandemic so I'm painting a picture that
someone comes up and thinks of a famous
person and I start to I do a painting
and then it's upside down and I flip it
around at the end is that what you're
thinking of yes yeah yeah and the thing
that I think stuns me the most is how
unbelievable you are as a painter thank
you very much
and the fact you could do that upside
down you can paint such an incredible
image upside down it's also stunning
um but that clearly is describing what
you've described there where you've
pulled in a love of painting yeah I I
think it's yeah I think all that's
really uh
otherwise what's left you know just it's
just hey look at me aren't I clever and
that's just not
you know that might be interesting for
audiences for a little bit
um maybe once and then that's that's
kind of it so I I yeah I bring what I
can to it and I just make I make sure
the shows are about something else you
know showman is about
how the things in life that are
difficult are actually the very things
that we share which weirdly was written
just before it was all due to go out
before lockdown started and it um was
going to go out the first week of
lockdown
and was assured about how the things in
life that isolated so actually the
things that we all tend to have in
common which then gets played out
literally for two years during lockdown
um so I've always tried to make them
about
something else something of value
um and I don't think I I love magic
obviously but I don't think in and of
itself it has
tremendous value as a childish way of
impressing people so it's what you what
can you bring to it
that will give it value and then I think
then you're into a much more interesting
um worthwhile area in your books about
happiness
um happy and a little happier one of the
things that surprises a lot of people is
that you're not a fan of goal setting
and having spoken to you now I can kind
of understand because you have a much
more
today this week do my best approach to
life but what's wrong with goal setting
in your point of view oh no there's
anything wrong with goal setting for
short-term goals obviously you know can
be very useful it's it's the long-term
stuff I think we just get a bit hung up
on it as a way of as a way of life you
know a friend of mine um it's a bit of a
always being a workaholic
um and
he certainly buys an account when he was
younger was made to feel that kind of
needed to achieve stuff in order to
feel valued you know which obviously is
what most workholics will say so he
decided he was going to build up a
company and and sell it and become a
multi-millionaire and that was sort of
the goal and then did spent and all the
time that I knew him he was building up
a company and
um sold it relatively young and had a
huge amount of money and then
she didn't know what to do with his life
it was miserable
um and as she found himself going to a
support group with a bunch of similar
millionaires that had all made the same
mistake and he'd sort of missed the fact
that actually it was the it was the
building up of the company that was is
what gave him a meaning in his life that
was that was what was important and it's
that old thing isn't it of you know the
you know the arrival at the end of the
journey is just it might just be taking
a coat off and putting your bag down
that might be all it is it's not
necessarily the destination you know
it's the you know it's the old thing
isn't it of the journey being what was
important but that was certainly he
realized that
um and that really changed his life
actually realizing
that what he thought was going to be
important wasn't important
um plus how do we know what's going to
make us happy that so many years before
you know it was so terrible at gauging
that
um we lose
flexibility depending how we set those
goals but we become too rigid in them
and it's like playing it's like playing
a game of chess schopenhauer talks about
this I was a really good analogy that
it's like starting a game of chess
deciding how you're going to play and
the strategy you're going to use and
you're how you're going to maneuver from
the start there is this other thing
playing which is you know life Fortune
stuff that's going to throw get thrown
back at you so how how can you decide
those things
why do we want goals do you think it
gives us a sense of certainty
well we need we it's about it's about
moving forward isn't it we need to it's
important because we need to navigate
through life and in the first half of
life I think it's it's really important
if you didn't have that optimistic sense
that you can
chase the castle in the air and somehow
get it just by setting those goals
I think life would be very difficult I
think actually it's I think it's
important I think it sure has
evolutionary value I think like it's
part of our impetus so it's not a bad
thing really
but
like all those things we just need to
check it and
just see its limitations I think a story
I see the goals that I had as a story
that gave my life meaning when I was
yeah
younger the meaning was kind of
misunderstood it was I thought if I got
the Lamborghini then I'd be happy and
important and worthy and shame would be
alleviated but as I as that failed me
yeah I realized that um I was gonna have
to
set about pursuing something else well
those are the two problems you either
get the goal yeah you succeed in it and
then what
or you don't and you've failed I mean
you're sort of
and the very thing that's giving you
pleasure the very thing that's giving
your life meaning which is moving
towards you know building up the company
or whatever it is
you're doing yourself out of your your
purposefully and intentionally moving to
the point where you can remove that
meaning from your life have you
developed any coping mechanisms for
adversity chapter three in your book A
book of secrets is about the role
friction has the relationship it has
with with happiness
and we've talked a few times about
adversity but is there any any sort of
tools that you've learned that you might
be able to impart that have helped you
to deal with when life throws [ __ ] at
you
well the big stoic thing of how can this
thing be fine and it's not they don't
exactly put it in that language but
that's the language I found
how could this thing be fine so first of
all
is what's happened which side of the
line is it is it within my control is it
my thoughts and actions or is it out of
my control is it something out in the
world of course it's always the latter
is always something out in the world in
which case how could it be fine how
could it how could that how could it be
okay that this thing is like that
um and not just to go oh it's fine it's
fine it's not just about saying it but
to actually let that thought sort of you
know drip into the soul I find that
very helpful that's also partly just my
personality my partner's has a much more
um
sort of anxious personality than I have
and that stuff doesn't help him at all
um but it certainly helps me
um another thing there's a great book by
David Destino called emotional success
and
I thought it was great he was talking
about motivation and how a lot of our
tools for motivation are very sort of
top down in the sense that you know well
if you do this for ten thousand hours or
you put in an hour a day for a whatever
um like a lot of kind of work to change
one habit
and he's talking about a bottom-up
approach of there are certain emotions
that if you get them into place they
naturally create a more motivational
State and he he's a psychologist and his
when he talks about motivation that the
way he's tested this
is talking about where you value your
future self
and what your future self needs more
than what you need in the moment right
so if you take the example of are you
going to study for your exam are you
going to go out and party well
the person that is going to not party
and study for the exam is valuing the
needs of that future self that's done
well in the exam more than the current
self that sat there and would like to go
out right so he's taking that as the
sort of the world of motivation we're
talking so he sets up various
um experiments to see what can you do to
maximize people's
uh you know the value they place on that
future self and the three emotions
um
again and again which help compassion
gratitude and having the right sort of
Pride about what you do a good Pride for
the stuff that you do well not the bad
sort of Pride where you go well I'm good
at this therefore I'm great at
everything but just having a a good sort
of comfortable pride in the stuff that
you do well
um so he would you know experiments
would be something happens outside the
room before the person comes in to do
the experiment that makes them feel
grateful about something and then they
come in and they have to do a task
that's impossible but how long do they
spend trying to do it and they'll spend
40 longer than somebody that wasn't
primed to feel grateful before they came
in and the Gratitude has nothing to do
with the experiment so seemingly
completely independent thing something
happens that make you makes you feel
compassion
um and then you come in and you have to
do some task and you do it better or for
longer or whatever these sort of skills
are that the motivated person has more
of
um one of the questions was uh
uh how many so is dollars but how many
dollars like if you could have a hundred
dollars a year from now or x amount now
what would that x amount be that would
balance it out and it's normally 17 like
it really makes no fiscal sense at all
but most people will say okay I'll take
17 now rather than a hundred right a
year from now that seems to be the
number that people go for but if you're
primed to feel grateful if you're if
you're asked the same question when
you're in a state of gratitude for
something again totally unrelated
um it goes up to 31 that was that was a
great sort of uh by the by finding when
they did the experiment it averaged out
of 31 in other words people were valuing
the future needs more than the need now
if that makes sense it could actually be
shown with something as simple as that
gone well I read a bit of chapter 12 of
your book
um was on exactly that and I actually
said before you arrived I sent it to my
friends I sent that one paragraph in
your book about that that instant
gratification delay graph because it
it when I say it makes sense it makes
absolutely no sense yeah like I can't
understand how gratitude how making
someone feel grateful with a completely
unrelated incident would make them
choose to have
um more money well we'll make them delay
their gratification in life it does
exactly and I think the reason why
there's no kind of rational link because
it's a sort of it's like an emotional
basis he's talking about an emotional
heart that then kind of
spirals upwards because if you if you
if you find yourself
acting more compassionately
which say just sometimes happens anyway
right you might just be feeling
compassion you might be feeling very
grateful to somebody that then affects
that person's behavior and then that
feeds back and affects yours and there's
a certain kind of upward spiral thing
that happens that definitely puts us in
I think a more
just a better kind of state than say
when we're feeling the opposite of those
things feeling hateful and resentful
um so I do get it I I sorry does that
mean that people that are lowering
gratitude are more short-termist in
their decision making they probably
binge foods that they probably shouldn't
have they probably make other kind of
Reckless decisions they probably
shouldn't make because of their own
state of emotions and gratefulness and
compassion
perhaps I mean it sounds like you'd have
to ask him I don't know I don't think he
says that in his book but I can
certainly imagine that again so if
you're going through your life feeling
generally resentful
I can't imagine that person being very
motivated it's so interesting it answers
actually a lot of questions that I've
had with like friends of mine where I've
wondered why they make such short-term
missed decisions but I think there's an
emotional question that I should really
be asking which is like how do you feel
and we don't we don't often pause to ask
that we kind of assume that their
character is they are lazy or just
stupid like bad at decisions whereas
really like go to work on the emotions
and you can change that which is
it's an it's a I thought it was a very
uh yeah very compelling way round of
looking at it rather than the normal
top-down approach we come across
love uh-huh
you described yourself as a bit of a
introvert and someone that likes their
own company yeah
um sounds a little bit like me what's
your journey been like with
understanding love and then at 35 you
came out
um
what's that Journey been like
well I've had two long relationships and
then um a few little bits in between
um and I think
there's definitely a lot of learning in
the first one that I think I've now
brought to the
second one of course what we do is it's
next you have another relationship you
bring all those lessons that you can't
you can't change them and you're in one
but you can you get to start afresh the
next time
um we're quite different as well it's
not like we're we're not similar people
at all I'm I have that sort of a bit of
emotional Detachment that I can easily
go to he is very um
engage and as as uh people the little on
the anxious side tend to be very sort of
hyper Vigilant about stuff so you know
packing to come to London to do this
shows two very very different worlds
always leads to argument I'm kind of
travel light and here's another but we
might even do this we might need this we
might need this bags and bags bags so uh
we see each other sometimes you know as
caricatures of ourselves because because
we're quite different in those in those
ways my kind of stoic uh
whatever
will seem to him just sometimes just to
be laziness or not really um
not engaging with something not that
thing not being not taking it seriously
and for me his
his what I see is uh anxiety or
impatience to him is a strong sense of
justice he has a real
strong sense of justice something's not
right he'll want to go and sort that
thing out and fix it um
and I think love for me is
allowing that other person
to be another person we'd probably start
off our relationships just projecting
everything we need onto a person and we
barely do them the service of you know
allowing them to exist as an independent
creature we sort of we just want them to
be the thing that we want them to be
um and I think if relationships are
going to have any
longevity at some point that has to
shift into actually this person is a
mystery and I might spend the rest of my
life trying to get to know this person
that that's I think that's okay and I
think that's also
the same within ourselves in the parts
of ourselves that we're we're um
alienated from again the things that we
just
put outside of the story
um the the that sense of what the other
is of the great mystery you know it's
there in Magic it's there in within
ourselves the sides of us that
you know we need to live more
comfortably with and in our
relationships as well here is a a great
mystery that we sit down with every day
and have breakfast with and talk to and
misunderstand and disappoint and
occasionally delight at each other and
and it's it's uh
you know it's kind of
wonderful and sometimes it's hard work
and and uh
but I think
seeing your partner somebody who could
spend a lifetime
getting to know
uh
and as a source of Wonder and mystery I
think is a
that's a very helpful thing one of the
messages that I took from that is about
expectations and being really conscious
that you keep your expectations in check
because when you don't frustration and
unhappiness
um might Prevail and I think about this
a lot with my partner who's the complete
opposite I consider myself to be like
very logical I need to I need to
understand everything I'm very
um maybe scientific in my viewpoint
whatever the opposite of that is she is
and so you can find yourself in
conversations where the basis of reality
you're conversating from is completely
different yeah she will believe that
that a rock has energy and that yeah and
I will
obviously not believe that but we're
completely opposites but that's also why
it works because there's not an
expectation that we become the other
person she will tell me something she
knows I don't believe
and at the end of her saying it she will
not wait for me to nod and agree yeah
because she knows it doesn't believe and
that's fine yeah and vice versa
and it's that's what when you sing
except that we're two different people
yeah actually being able to do that and
her not trying to change me into like a
spiritual whatever me not trying to turn
her into a scientist yes allows for the
upside of that difference which is like
I can Marvel at the world she lives in
and go oh that's interesting I'm gonna
try that you know what I mean and also I
think a big Allied to that is to think
of not which is such a a guy thing to do
isn't it it's not fixing yeah not
um most of our frustrations
come from the fact we just haven't
really been heard or seen or understood
during the day so we've been bashing our
heads against some wall we come home and
hers yeah exactly exactly so we they
come home
and then just offload this stuff and
when because I I know I do it when my
partner does this to me but he sort of
offloads all this frustration and I'm
sure you do it too it sounds like you do
is to go into this mode where we're
saying well it's okay it's probably just
this and why don't we think about it in
this different way and we're just doing
exactly the same thing they've had all
day we're just not hearing
um uh
but it's just not it's not an intuitive
thing is that you sort of that is such a
such an easy mode to go into
um
Darren are you happy that was the name
of your book
I think so yeah I think I think as I've
got all the happiness is
it was
easy to say I remember being asked that
when I was
single for a while
um by Hugh Grant of all people we were
sat opposite each other at dinner and
talking about happiness maybe I was
writing the book at the time I don't
know and um
he said are you are you happy though and
it was he was said it in a sort of a
mood of like no one's really no one's
really happy are they
um and maybe just the way he asked it
but I said yes and said it very
confidently and felt it very confidently
and he didn't think he didn't know what
to make of that uh or maybe he just
didn't believe it and now when you ask I
still feel it's yes but I think I think
things are more complicated I think
there's a more complicated in
relationships I've got older
um
51 and I think I think that's a good
sort of um
you know I said things things just
change the currents of Life shift a
little bit so I am but I uh
I think it's
it's a I don't think it's about
happiness first of all I think it's
about meaning and it's about you know
things in life that are bigger than you
and what you how you throw yourselves
into those things which is what gives
religion its meaning you know that that
need for Transcendence or finding the
thing that's bigger than you we all need
it somewhere
because if you don't have meaning in
your life that's that's when you have
problems not really happiness is sort of
um a very difficult thing to pin down
but uh
and we can be unhappy but it's when we
when we feel meaningless that it's that
it things get bad
um it's a bit of a [ __ ] question isn't
it are you happy
in many respects yeah
you know what is it you know things that
used to mean the story of a life it was
something you couldn't say about anybody
until they were dying and look back over
their whole life you know it's meant our
relationship with God we weren't even
supposed to be happy on this Earth
because of uh you know because it was
something that we could only have
through Union with with God it's meant
so many things over the ages but now it
does just sort of mean a mood
um uh which is uh is it makes it sort of
a difficult one to answer but I think
I think Life Is Life is good it's just
interesting and sometimes difficult but
you know ultimately
good way I think life is full of [ __ ]
questions and in some respects it's like
a form of misdirection the fact that I
yeah we never supposed to reflective
questions are actually valid because if
I'd said what number is Fork hmm you it
mean you would say that's not a valid
question but because are you happy or
the questions like have you found your
passion there's an assumption in there
that there's one of them there's one
passion you have to go searching for it
yeah all in loaded into the question and
nobody nobody when you ask those
questions pauses to think of whether the
question is valid and then the the
frustration we encounter when we can't
properly fit into a invalid question I
see I see that causing so many young
people so much pain because culture pops
up these like questions you've got is it
love
well is it love I mean it alludes to a
yes or no answer and then I have to know
that your definition of love what you
mean by that because as I was saying I
love peanut butter I love my dog I love
my mum and it's all very unhelpful like
this is why I love going back to what
you said the star like how'd you feel
nice open question which allows for a
bit more maneuvering yeah I think people
are tormented by these um questions yeah
yeah your show
there's nothing like it that exists in
the event space really on TV I mean I
prefer doing it seeing it in person
because obviously cameras can create
certain Dimensions but seeing it in
person just bends the mind because it
makes almost anything seem possible in
life I'm talking about sales and
ambition and creativity and Imagination
if that's possible then anything can
become possible and I think that's a
cause of great inspiration
um
so I would just employ anyone that's
listening to this if you're looking for
a once in a lifetime very unique
experience that you can't get anywhere
else they've got to go and see the show
they've gone I really mean that I'm not
just that you didn't tell me to say this
I really need you there you know yes
yeah you'll never know yeah but thank
you but I really really mean that it's
there's nothing like it so
great day idea great family idea so I'm
definitely going to come what can I
expect that's different from the other
shows that I've been to
well it is
it's got a real heart to it this one you
get all the feels as some people say
um it's uh
it's I it's also got I mean it's got the
best if this is all right to say the
best reviews of anything I've ever done
in 20 odd years which is nice to know
because it is such a personal show so
that's a um that's a lovely
thing that has been received so well
um I do swear the old the audience to
secrecy
um so it's hard to go into details um
other than yeah it is about
the things that connect us as people and
then how the difficult things in life
are the things that join us up it's also
show based on audience participation
like like they all are and I should say
I I would hate the idea of being dragged
up on stage so I throw out frisbees to
choose people which means it's the
easiest thing to hand to the person next
year if you you know if it lands on your
lap and you don't want to get involved
so there's no pressure to get involved
at all but it is a it's a big show of
audience participation
and it's it's more than More Than People
expect I hope we always try and make the
show properly
over deliver give you give you more than
you thought it would I'm so excited I
genuinely really excited thank you so
much for your time we we have a closing
tradition on this podcast we're the last
guest asks a question for the next guest
and they don't know who they're leaving
it the question for oh fantastic I get
to see it when I open the books excuse
me if I take a while to read the
handwriting um oh this is for me right
yes great oh God okay top or bottom
I can imagine I wonder if that was the
question
if you could only speak with call
C touch
four people
for the next four years
who would they be
I feel this is quite a yeah boring
answer but it's honest so my mom
uh partner
probably number two really good friends
Sharky and Stephen I'd have to include
Jenny in there somewhere so maybe they
could alternate weekends or something
um
yeah friendships really mean a lot to me
now as I get as I get older I'm not old
but you know getting older I've been
really I think it happens something like
on your 50th birthday or something
suddenly your friendships really mean a
huge amount to you
um and they didn't before
they always did but just not in such a
conscious why what changes why I don't
know it's just a real
real sentimental like valuing of them
Nostalgia as well like really um I just
find myself just
that was kind of yeah sentimental sort
of uh leanings
um and my friends just suddenly they've
obviously always meant a lot to me
because I've been my friends but
suddenly even more so I love
meeting up with people I haven't seen
for years now I love
doing that much more than I used to
um so yeah I'm that's it Mom partnering
up a couple of really good friends
um
uh that doesn't include my dog
is
I forgot I didn't forget I had two dogs
but I have a clear favorite which is uh
unfortunate for the other one I was only
thinking of doodle and I forgot about
humbug it's okay I said people so yeah
so sorry that's not a very clear answer
but lovely question
thank you so much for your time thank
you for the inspiration thank you for
coming and doing this you're someone
that I've been honestly quite obsessed
with since for the last 10 years
watching on TV watching on Channel 4
coming to your shows and stuff so it
feels like a real honor to get to speak
with you and as I said I read your book
in the jungle it was very much the basis
in the jungle you didn't say that yeah
yeah so I took it took a brief I took a
suitcase out to the jungle and I was I
wanted books on happiness and yours was
on the Shelf so I took it was it that
one was a happy it was the yellow one
yeah happy
um and I'll be honest I this sounds like
because I bought it not knowing it was
you interestingly yeah yeah and then
when I saw I got to the jungle and I saw
the name on it I couldn't I had to
Google to check it with you because I
couldn't believe you'd written a book on
happiness and you get this a lot don't
you yeah I do and a while back I got a
um the only time I've ever dropped my
own name trying to get a restaurant
table
um in SoHo and I did and I got the table
suddenly we have felt ah I pulled that
off went in and then at the end of the
meal the waiter said would you mind
signing one of your books so yeah of
course and he came back with angels and
demons oh [ __ ] it's fantastic foreign
thank you so much Dan thank you so much
for having me watch what a joy thank you
as you might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry and this
piece by crafted when I put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is
um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafty jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my God
[Music]